monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chaque collègue je souhaite
attirer votre attention monsieur le
ministre
sur les milliers de personnes que l'état
l'obligation d'héberger en raison de
leur statut de demandeur d'asile
déboutés du droit d'asile ou deux sans
papiers maire d'une commune qui
accueille pendant la période hivernale
une quarantaine d'adultes et d'enfants
je suis inquiet m'interroge face à la
demande en constante augmentation des
demandeurs d'asile et de sa gestion
dernièrement les 28 maires de la
communauté d'agglomération de grenoble
ont reçu un courrier du président de
l'intercommunalité dans lequel il
rappelé je cite les lieux d'accueil
gérée par l'état sont totalement saturés
et ne peuvent plus faire face à ces
arrivées régulières
le corollaire de cet état de fait était
une situation de précarité qui se
diffuse à l'ensemble des routes du
territoire au delà des zones urbaines
prioritairement concerner l'état
compétent dans ce dossier m'a
officiellement annoncé son impossibilité
de maintenir son effort financier lié à
ses obligations
faute de crédits disponibles
cette situation démontre la nécessité de
mettre en oeuvre un dispositif sanitaire
et sociale spécifique pour répondre aux
problèmes de délais d'instruction des
dossiers par l'office français de
protection des réfugiés et apatrides
ofpra de gérer des flux à des chefs des
départements de places en centres
d'accueil de sécurité de prostitution de
scolarité ces questions se posent à la
france mais les réponses dépasse
largement les frontières du territoire
national or les récentes mesures prises
par certains pays de l'union européenne
visant à réduire les entrées migratoire
confirme qu'il ya urgence à revoir notre
politique communautaire selon souhaite
faire preuve déficiences en matière
d'accueil des populations de la sécurité
n'est pas assurée dans leur pays
d'origine
et si l'on veut éviter que ce que l'on
pourrait appeler un appel d'air je
souhaite savoir si le gouvernement
envisage de mobiliser des instances
européennes afin de rendre plus
efficiente la politique communautaire
d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile
ici il peut solliciter ces mêmes
instances afin de créer un statut de
minorité garantissant leur protection
dans leur pays d'origine
quand celui ci est membre de l'union
européenne bien sûr j'aimerais également
savoir quand pourra être opéré au niveau
national une réduction des délais
d'instruction des dossiers traités par
l'ofpra la procédure pouvant s'avérer
souvent longue 12 à 18 mois
enfin je souhaite savoir si les
gouvernement à l'intention de proposer
une gestion de l'accueil de
l'hébergement et de l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'asile à l'échelle
départementale pour une meilleure prise
en charge des demandes 1 d'autant les
préfectures de moyens et de matériel
adapté
merci merci la parole est à monsieur
manuel valls ministre de l'intérieur
merci monsieur le président madame
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur michel savin vous avez fait
part de préoccupations quant aux
modalités d'accueil et d'hébergement des
demandeurs d'asile je rejoins une grande
partie de vos préoccupations
le droit d'asile est un droit
fondamental et la france doit honorer
ses engagements internationaux de
protection des personnes persécutées
menacés dans leur pays d'origine où
devront d'ailleurs transcrire dans notre
droit le paquet asile qui a été négocié
depuis plusieurs années au sein de
l'union européenne le droit d'asile
n'est donc pas un droit à l'immigration
d'un droit de protection
il convient de veiller donc à ce que la
politique d'asile ne soit pas dévoyé
les demandeurs déboutés après qu'ils
aient fait valoir leur droit de recours
n'ont pas le droit à priori de se
maintenir sur le territoire entre 2008
et 2012 le nombre de demandeurs d'asile
a augmenté de 73% et cette progression
continue la france est au deuxième rang
des pays de destination des demandeurs
d'asile en europe après l'allemagne
cette évolution a provoqué une
augmentation importante vous signaliez
d'ailleurs des délais d'instruction de
la demande grâce au recrutement de
quarante cinq officiers de protection
supplémentaire à l'ofpra
ces délais commencent à diminuer mais le
rythme est insuffisant
ce phénomène se combine avec des effets
de concentration des flux dans certaines
régions et dans certains départements
dont le vôtre et sur l'agglomération
grenobloise comme sur l'agglomération
proche de lyon il en résulte comme vous
le soulignez une très forte pression sur
les dispositifs d'hébergement
en dix ans les choses simplement notre
politique d'asile atteint ses limites
si bien que pour la préserver je dirais
même pour la sauver il nous faut la
réformer profondément
oui vous avez raison il faut mener
évidemment ces discussions au niveau
européen et puis il faut agir évidemment
au plan national
le premier ministre a annoncé la
création de 4000 places de cada
supplémentaires 2000 sont d'ores et déjà
disponibles mais compte tenu des
contraintes budgétaires nous ne pourrons
pas multiplier à l'infini les
hébergements
si le fonctionnement de notre système
d'asile restent inchangés tous ces
efforts seront vains avec eux d'ailleurs
vous le soulignez également le risque
d'un appel d'air et puis la confusion ou
des publics
je pense notamment à ceux qui se
retrouvent sans papiers qui sont aussi
présents dans ces dispositifs
il est donc urgent d'agir d'autant plus
que la france doit comme je vous le
disais très prochainement transposer ces
directives européennes
celle ci vise à contribuer à
l'achèvement du régime d'asile européen
commun qui fondait sur une harmonisation
accrue des politiques des états membres
et un haut niveau de protection la mise
en oeuvre de cet objectif doit assurer à
tout demandeur d'asile
quel que soit l'état membre dans lequel
ces 2 - d'examiner qu'ils bénéficient
des mêmes droits des mêmes garanties la
même qualité d'examen donc si nous ne
réformons pas nous aurons des
difficultés supplémentaires
et puis par ailleurs il faut qu'au
niveau européen et avec mon collègue
allemand nous menons des initiatives
dans ce sens dire clairement les choses
quand nous avons toute une série de
demandeurs d'asile qui viennent d'un
certain nombre de pays notamment des
balkans qui ne sont pas d'ailleurs
membre de l'union européenne je pense à
l'albanie ou à la macédoine il nous faut
une réponse appropriée au niveau
européen et enfin j'ai décidé de lancer
le 15 juillet dernier une concertation
nationale sur l'asile en nommant deux
médiateurs
la sénatrice valérie létard et le député
jean louis tourenne tous deux élus
locaux expériences professionnelles
politiques et personnelles que je crois
complémentaires tous les acteurs du
droit d'asile sont autour de la table
les associations de la chaire les
administrations mais aussi les élus
l'adf la mf et les villes concernées par
les problématiques de l'asie nous avons
choisi deux parmi d'autres mais ce sont
les mêmes problèmes
on connaît ailleurs je pense aux villes
de mulhouse et de rennes
qui s'impliqueront dans la concertation
et puis il y aura plusieurs déplacements
sur le terrain j'ai enfin demandé à
quatre préfets dont les territoires sont
en première ligne de nous accompagner et
l'angle européen ne sera évidemment pas
oublié à partir de leurs recommandations
fin octobre au plus tard
c'est une vraie refonte du dispositif
d'asile en france qui vous sera proposé
notamment pour mieux répartir l'accueil
sur le territoire comme le font déjà un
certain nombre de pays c'est l'une des
pistes proposées mais je ne veux pas
conclure cette concertation alors
qu'elle vient à peine de commencer en
tout cas monsieur le sénateur soyez
certain de ma préoccupation est de la
nécessité d'apporter des réponses
rapides et fortes à ce qui est en train
de devenir un vrai problème qui risque
de mettre en cause ce droit fondamental
qu'est le droit d'asile
mais si nous continuons ainsi il sera
des voiliers et je pense que nos
concitoyens à travers leurs élus et les
questions légitimes que vous avez posé
auront des interrogations profondes sur
cette question là vous voyez
j'en suis conscient merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur savin j'entends bien
monsieur le ministre votre souhait de
réformer le système du droit d'asile et
sachez que je serai prêt pas seulement à
soutenir toutes les propositions qui
seront faits pour réformer ce système et
vous l'avez rappelé le ministre notre
pays enregistre une hausse très
importante un des demandeurs d'asile
plus de 60000 encore en 2012 et vous
l'avez rappelé aussi la plupart d'eux
qu'ils viennent de provenant de pays
balkans phénomène qui risque que en
train de s'accentuer encore dans les
prochaines semaines et prochains mois si
aucune décision n'est prise rapidement
donkey je suis d'accord avec vous il est
urgent de passer aux actes
face aux conditions inhumaines
d'installation et des risques engendrés
tente en termes de sécurité que
l'hygiène et pour soi donc il faut
adapter la politique sur le droit
d'asile afin que soient compatibles et
vous l'avez préciser avec nos capacités
d'accueil
donc nous attendons avec impatience des
dispositions merci